2021 was the year of coups
in total six countries experienced at
least one attempt
five of which were successful
that's as many as the previous six years
from 2015 to 20 put together and over
three times the two decade average
the last time the world saw this many in
a single calendar year in fact was after
the fall of the soviet union in 1991.
the un secretary general went so far as
to call it an epidemic
clearly coups are not a thing of the
past
but what's remarkable is how little
they've changed
in 1968 political scientist edward
lutwalk released coup d'etat a practical
handbook
essentially a step-by-step cookbook for
would-be dictators
today over 50 years later the same basic
recipe is used to seize control of
countries like mali guinea sudan and
myanmar
these dictators even look the same as
they did in the 60s
so how do coups work why do these steps
seem to transcend time and place
and what does that tell us about how to
prevent them
sponsored by story blocks where you can
find over a million high quality stock
videos for all your creative projects
to answer our questions we're going to
have to temporarily inhabit the mind of
an aspiring machiavellian autocrat
our very first step is to select a
target
as americans learned on january 6th no
country is immune from coups and it
always pays to stay vigilant against
them
still there are some characteristics
that make a coup more or less likely to
succeed
we see that in their geographic
distribution
coups are not as common as this chart
from earlier might suggest
rather a few countries seem to be
trapped in a perpetual cycle
of the countries which have seen at
least one attempt since 1950 the average
number during that period was 5
or once every 14 years
they've been a regular feature of thai
politics for instance since 1912
and this is just a list of the
successful ones
if you include failed attempts there
have been at least 30.
the sahel region of africa likewise has
been referred to as a coup belt
since 1950 sudan has experienced 16 and
both sierra leone and ghana 10.
many of these countries are poor yes but
not all poor countries are represented
here
so what do these in particular have in
common
for starters they tend to have a high
concentration of power
as we'll see coups rarely command a
numerical advantage
they're surgical operations not
overwhelming displays of firepower
our ideal country has a definite
political center a single capital city
home to all the administrative and
bureaucratic headquarters
aka a single point of failure
the greater the separation of powers the
more branches of government will have to
infiltrate
the same is true of redundancy in
general
syria's assad for example maintained not
two three or even four but five separate
intelligence services
one might defect but it's very unlikely
that all four will
besides someone has to spy on the spies
next the ideal target has low political
participation
where revolutions are built on passion
coups on the other hand thrive on apathy
dissatisfaction with the current
government of course is preferable to
satisfaction but the more important
dimension is engagement
though we'll probably want to package
our actions with some ideological window
dressing remember we the elite are
performing the coup not the masses
we're not soliciting rebellion
quite the contrary we want to avoid
civilian intervention
the population should know very little
about politics
and above all believe their involvement
simply doesn't matter
they're all the same anyway and who am i
to change things are music to our ears
now that we've chosen a target it's time
to move on to step two
infiltrate
this crucial phase will almost entirely
determine our ultimate success or
failure
but set down your aviators and take off
your beret because this is largely an
academic exercise
our job is to draw one giant org chart
of the current government
this includes everyone in the
bureaucracy military and party from the
prime minister all the way down to his
limo driver
except unlike one you'd find on the
national website or wikipedia ours will
include only the real sources of power
corruption and simple mismanagement are
likely to have produced a large number
of pencil pushers and ceremonial leaders
who we can safely ignore
we can cross off for example the 80 year
old general who everyone knows is all
but retired
now what we're left with is effectively
a map of power
our next task is to divide everyone into
one of three categories
allies indifferent pragmatists and
enemies
to do this we'll start by asking do we
absolutely need this person's active
support
if the answer is yes whether because
they're a top decision maker or simply
know the email passwords our only option
is to buy their support
if there are multiple candidates for a
given role will pick the less qualified
among them
we want someone who feels underutilized
someone who's been passed over for
promotions
with less to lose they'll more readily
join our cause where we've promised them
a shiny new office
some of course will be tempted to alert
the authorities of our plan
luckily we anticipate this and raise the
stakes
your superiors are already on board we
tell them
joining us should feel like the safe
option
we've now established our small circle
of allies
but that still leaves a wide cast of
characters ranging from powerful
military commanders to glorified malkops
to identify the real threats we'll
simply ask
is this person loyal to the ruling party
our enemies are those for whom the
answer is yes
many will be loud but powerless
figureheads
they may even incidentally help our
cause thanks to their own unpopularity
the others will make sure are distracted
at the time of the coup
off fighting some distant war for
example or we may even create for them a
wild goose chase
everyone else which constitutes the vast
majority are indifferent
pragmatists not loyal to any particular
party or ideology they'll sit back in
silence while the coup unfolds waiting
to see how things play out
no need to worry about them we'll slowly
win their support as we consolidate
power
which brings us to step three
freeze
if we've carried out the first two steps
well this phase will seem shockingly
easy
with our allies in place and awaiting
instructions one could argue the coup
has already occurred it's just that no
one knows it yet
this again is what differentiates a coup
although it's often performed by the
military it is not primarily a military
operation
ideally in fact no one will be killed or
even hurt it's best to avoid creating a
martyr or risk breeding discontent
besides we have neither an advantage in
strength nor numbers
we'll begin this phase by freezing all
movement both that of people and
information
airports will be shut down tv stations
taken off the air roads blocked and the
internet cut
lack of information will make civilian
resistance difficult the average person
won't even know what's going on
the disorder will be indistinguishable
from say a natural disaster
next while our allies form a perimeter
around the capital a small tactical team
will covertly enter the palace and
arrest the current government
upon noticing the turmoil whatever army
police and security forces are outside
the perimeter will make their way to it
but our secret weapon remember is chaos
and confusion
at the perimeter they'll discover not
hostile foreign targets but calm
soldiers wearing their exact same
uniforms
nine times out of ten occam's razor will
prevail
when faced with uncertainty the vast
majority of soldiers will do as they're
trained await further instructions
assuming incompetence
even if they suspect something is fishy
few if any will risk their lives on a
hunch
once again apathy will play in our favor
by now the opposition has been silenced
the public thoroughly confused and the
physical symbols of power occupied
it may seem as though the coup is
complete
but note the word symbols
power is not merely the possession of
the telephone on the resolute desk but
the odds that the person on the other
end will follow the order spoken into it
we may possess the telephone at this
point but one could say there
effectively is no government
our task is to somehow transform this
symbolic power into actual power
what we're attempting is a slight of
hand trick we begin by deceiving just
one person
convincing them that we already have
power
their belief in our power thus becomes
our foothold something tangible we can
point to as evidence of our authority
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
a lie that we hope becomes true by
virtue of speaking it
it's faking it until you make it
but be careful
this positive feedback loop can also
work against us
slow down or lay bear the seams of our
rule and resistance will develop
and as soon as one person resists all
others will be emboldened
speed therefore is of the utmost
importance
with each building we control flag we
raise and law we pass the greater the
rebel or comply risk calculus will fall
in our favor
in practical terms this means as soon as
possible we'll perform the ultimate coup
cliche
a victorious televised address
this is why the old government was
illegitimate and this is why we needed
to intervene for the good of the nation
slash democracy
economy
to increase our authoritative momentum
we'll immediately institute a dramatic
change in policy
redistribute land kick out foreigners or
do something else rash
oh and by the way in case you don't see
things the same way there's no point
resisting anyway the battle has already
been fought and won
fill in the blanks it's mad libs really
much of the international community will
no doubt condemn our rule but they will
inevitably recognize it as it becomes
clear they have no other choice
now although the active part of our coup
is now over statistically speaking the
most dangerous phase has only now begun
recall from earlier the chart of coup
since 1950
of them 242 were successful and
remarkably even
244 were failures
what this means is that if and granted
this is a big if your coup makes it past
the planning stage and becomes public it
has an almost 50 percent chance of
succeeding
coups as their similarity across time
demonstrates aren't really that
difficult to pull off
at least in these
countries what is difficult is holding
on to that power
that's because if you think about it a
coup is both the product of a lack of
legitimacy and a cause of it
where they occur frequently they become
normalized
each successful operation invigorates
the next in a downward bottomless spiral
the public slowly loses hope believing
none of it matters
apathy sets in apathy which makes the
next one even easier
thus while it's often not enough
resistance however small and however
symbolic still matters
myanmar for instance continues to
bravely defy authority refusing despite
the country's turbulent and at times
repetitive history to succumb to
numbness
and it's through images like these that
we thousands of miles away connect with
these important stories
video transcends time place language and
culture it's the most compelling way of
telling a story which is why i've used
hundreds of clips from story blocks in
my videos over the years including this
one
we all know what bad stock footage looks
like from the bland corporate performed
ads we're constantly bombarded with
what sets story blocks apart is their
collection of over a million high
quality and realistic video clips i'm
sure i don't need to describe the
difference you can just see it
for this very video i searched thailand
for example narrowed it down to include
only 4k clips over 10 seconds and was
still left with 39 pages to choose from
best of all with a single story block
subscription you get access to unlimited
downloads usually each clip would cost
20 50 or even a hundred dollars
so whether you're a solo entrepreneur an
aspiring filmmaker or youtuber
storyblocks is the go-to resource for
quick easy to find and high quality
video
click the link on screen now or in the
description and sign up for their
unlimited all access plan today